[Music]
my next guest plays Dennis on the hugely
popular FX series It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia let's take a look
time out time out though you said you
were good at this I am good it's just
yeah this shirt is like ridiculously
tightens restricting my place so I'm
just gonna pop it off Oh what do you
think about this about what what I'm
presenting you I think you look really
pale do you need some sunscreen it's
it's the first of the season I haven't
had a chance to get a base going Dennis
Dennis what do you think of the package
anything what come here what I thought
you say you weren't gonna hit on your
character likes to take his shirt off
yeah and this is sparking comments on
Twitter what are people saying oh yeah
yeah actually after that episode aired I
got a lot of comments on Twitter about
how pink my nipples are people think
your nipples are very pink yeah America
wants to know you know what's up with
this guy sniffs you know and that's a
good question actually because they are
very pink and they're very small and
very proud of them
okay let's take a quick look again okay
I'm just trying to examine well they do
seem kind of on the pink side they are
that is an unreached photograph and yeah
I don't know why they're honestly
they're not that pink I don't know why I
don't know what our DPS doing in the
color correction studio to make them
that pink what do you think he's
spending hundreds of thousands of
dollars that's what I think pinking up
your nips yeah surprise we met this guy
I know I I know weird he's a weird guy
this is a tree didn't put lipstick on
him or something I'm not totally sure
hey now you do don't get me wrong but
you seem proud of your nipples you seem
like you're bringing them up you wonder
you seem like you're kind of cocky about
the fact that you've got these well you
know what's not to be proud of I mean
they're they're beautiful small they're
beautiful small pink nips
stupidest conversation I've ever had
I've been doing this almost 20 years and
this is the dumbest point my wife was
the first person to ever comment on how
beautiful mine my nipples are Julie yeah
I didn't think wives commented on that
kind of thing don't they
does your wife not know she doesn't know
anywho a big fan of my nips yeah my wife
is your wife no my mine oh I don't know
both of my dime nips what does she call
them your dime nips well because because
they they're the size of a dime all
right we got to find out if that's true
I heard this is a possibility I have a
dine here okay let's go find out this is
the kind of show we have so let's go for
it yeah let's find out right am i right
America are you am i right America are
you gonna administer the dime no you're
gonna I'm not gonna admit it's no you
administer you want me to administer the
dime yeah bro okay this is like a Mardi
Gras episode okay I'm so gross I'm so
gross and pale okay
so they let's see if these entities are
dime size nips
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes we cut yeah
I'll never spend this time leave me
forever
I wouldn't what is wrong I don't know I
learned that trick from Charlie Rose his
does that on his show all the time
classic I do now you your clothes or
your character's clothes come off so
often on the show that they've maze and
in the It's Always Sunny field ever has
made a novelty mug yeah and and this is
a trick mug and we have one right here
oh yeah yeah we have one It's Always
Sunny Philadelphia mug right there and
then there's your character that's
Dennis right there yeah it's very nice
and then if you add hot water apparently
you have a nice hot drink you pour that
in there yes I've got hot water is dimes
back here I have everything I need back
here
and apparently I'm told that the hot
water eventually yeah make this shirt
disappear now some say this isn't good
television right now but I say it's
amazing television
[Applause]